I spent a lot of time in karate but you
don't suck at karate no you're you're
brown belt level n but then I don't get
the brown belt it's not that you suck at
karate karate sucks karate does sucks
karate does sucks karate sucks at
[Laughter]
[Music]
youate welcome back to careful boys
where we're talking about what is
something you're terrible at that you
wish you could do well ooh dude7 things
bro sing probably I think this room
coulding sing play piano have some sort
of Music guitar inclination everybody's
got to pick their top two okay top why
not top one okay you want the video to
last 3 minutes grab Rim dude grab Rim
grab Rim's good but not even be good at
basketball just just touch the I just
touched it touch the bottom of the net
If I Could Touch the bottom of the net
bro damn oh my God having those kind of
hops but being able to Windmill that' be
tough oh my goodness dunking and singing
is probably a good I don't be good at
surfing surfing be sick I just I'm a
professional paddler right now I can't
even catch a you just paddle and then
paddle back in I went five times and I
caught one weight surfing is hard though
did you go hey but when you catch the
wave it's the best there's nothing
there's nothing like catching a wave y
cuz the guys I go with won't let me do
the beginner waves so I'm just crashing
every time hey but also too like isn't
there just hella people always on on the
on the swells is what they call it
depends where you go are you like are
you like um you're like keu in Point
Break like everyone around these too
hardcore yeah but they're really nice
okay but they like hardcore stuff but
they're really nice and they're just
like we're not that kind of teacher you
can't go to the baby and I'm like all
right so I go how you going learn yeah
it's hard it's scary too cuz the waves
are like it's like like this it's like
this tall I'm like tall that's like
twice as big as that's way too crazy cuz
the timing of how you got to catch that
wave is different than so I ride it like
a body board and I nose dive damn that's
scary too bro scary there's one time I
caught it and it was like toward the end
too but I wish I was better at it cuz I
I see so many people having fun and I'm
like one day I'll have as much fun as
you and I won't be coming home with just
salt water in my
ear a carve dude the way that they hit
the water and then o so that's one thing
TI one oh there's two things right you
can do whatever you want B only wants
one oh I don't know what well no you
said two you said two that's my one
thing part one it's the skill that we
want to be really good at right or
something you suck at right now that you
wish you had two you're terrible at but
you wish you could do one I remember one
time I woke up and I was [__] pissed
I wasn't a professional singer yet yet
and I was I just I just I was like mad I
not going to happen soon enough thank
God yeah and then I was like I was like
half asleep and I'm like why am I not a
[__] singer [__] and then I
tried to do karaoke on my phone and then
I my voice was cracking I couldn't even
hit the key and I'm like I'm not a son
of a musician and then I got up and I
said I'm going to do comedy but aren't
you a son of a two musicians I am but I
don't live up to that you felt like an
imposter bro and his father left so it's
only like he's terrible at accepting who
he is yeah what would you guys like to
do dude singing is on my list too why
can't why okay so singing is we can
actually get good at it it just takes
[__] practice why don't we practice
okay you go first cuz nobody want to be
singing like that all the time bro you
can make lots ofbody singing at this
level Okay the reason why I I really
want to is because I hate how I sing
right now it's cuz everybody's like oh
yeah you can like hold a tune or
whatever the [__] right I'm not like
terrible I feel like being limbo in the
middle is like terrible I'd rather just
suck and be entertaining at karaoke
versus like oh he's like trying and
that's kind of cute what if we start
being all right feel like really awkward
cuz it's like you either like try to be
entertaining that's the best yeah yeah
or or you like kind of try and it's like
kind of try is weird yeah that's what
I'm saying but like I want to try but
then it's like it's weirder so you don't
try and it's like it's either your
William Hung or your
[__] I don't know you don't someone
else who's really good but then song
choice is a big part of that oh yeah
yeah so I stick to the other [__] like
Niel back and Forget About Dre and [__]
hey that's Nikki's karaoke song Nick huh
Nickelback no Nikki my wife that's her
karaoke song your wife is nickel back I
mean who would you want to sing like if
you could like had
anybody's like anyone anybody's Voice or
range or style yeah you want James Brown
nah
Elis James Brown proud maybe because I
happen to be listening to right now I'll
go for something like a teddy swims or a
Jack Garrett basically just like a
Soulful R&B that has like a lot of like
range but yeah it's a little bit more
raspy edgy versus like overly clean or
just like like Sinatra yeah but that' be
[__] hot that's pretty SI honestly
that's the one i' pick be AER just seen
the OG super hot New York New York get
out of here dud you to smoke cigars and
wear cool hats come on can we do that I
want to smoke cigars and wear cool hat I
want to smoke cigars dude Vegas is a
great place for that if you're ever
there [__] I well I will be there fool
all right but then when I'm there I'm
just resting because that's my only
place that I can rest I'm just resting
when they ice skating with Bart I'm like
cool I'm here but like you don't know
how to ice skate what happened I don't
like the ice skate I don't like you guys
didn't want Steve to go ice cream no it
was okay ta was like pissed cuz we all
went to go go to this like thing where
there was like Christmas lights and [__]
and then there was too many people on
the I was actually out of town but it's
fine and then there was too many people
on the ice skating list and then Tao was
[__] sad and I'm all like man shut up
I'm sadder than your [__] ass and then
he's all like can we go next time and
then I was like yeah I'll take you next
time so then we decided to go to that
one spot and we finally went ice skating
because I promised his [__] ass that's
cool but it was actually just bar G
taking him and inviting me yeah you're
third whe in him big time and they're
like oh my God he's coming it's fine
what a family moment Joe can you take
the photos please yeah I just wanted to
see him fall that was my number one goal
I just want to see Tao fall so he can
get back up he he didn't get a chance to
say that part but that's what he meant
what's something you're terrible at but
wish you could do well Ryan AE is there
anything you're bad
at here's here's a no this's a realistic
one like he sucking it's on the it's a
realistic one I I want to whistle I
can't whistle shut the [__] up can't
whistle wet your lips no way are you
serious that's not a good try this is my
honest try
like you're whistling no that's not
whist done it in like eight years that's
what
good no I can't try the inhale
version I'll be here all day you can't
whistle loser as a kid all the way till
now I always like even when I drive the
whole time I'm just going
[__] like I'm just like in agony cuz can
I tell something you probably just spent
too much time on the keys and not on the
[__] O's dude no I wish I could
whistle I learned how to whistle like a
year ago bro what what happened what
happened I just kept I kept inhaling
let's hear
it I just keep sound like mine huh hey
that's a real whistle take that back
appointment with is the
best you hear that that's my best right
now so what you're saying is you're so
good at everything that you just wish
you could whistle better no I wanted to
learn how to whistle yeah that's [__]
hardcore I wanted to learn how to
whistle since before I could do anything
this guy's like oh no dude this is real
one I I just wish I could tie my
shoes what the heck so my grandpa so my
grandpa my grandpa's such a troll he
taught his parakeet how to
go to the cat that's TI that great
that's cool so then that's the only
reason I even know how to whistle is so
that I could help reinforce the parakeet
like thing so yeah wow see look that's
really cool yeah that's because I suck
at everything else yeah he's bad at it
but like everything else to me is just a
it's it's just a matter of time and
effort and like dedication but I no
matter what I do I can't whistle that's
kind that kind of sucks maybe you got
dry lips huh yeah got those dry have a
condition dude we should talk to smack
does he have dry
lips you ever see those guys doing these
knife tutorials and [__] and then like
they do [__] I wish I was good at
that a he sick you don't want to start
night fighting CQC combat you could be
good at that though right yeah he can't
do it he said no I spent a lot of time
in karate but you don't suck at karate
no you're you're brown belt level nah
but then I don't get the brown belt it's
not that you suck karate karate sucks
karate does sucks karate does sucks
karate sucks at
you sucks at Jo's col so true sucks oh
[__] so true I want to be like this in a
night fight come on sucker that's cool
you know how they used to always do that
the bad guys suck be 80s bad guy all day
I wonder why they did that like that's
like the worst thing to do it's hard to
track it's Dynamic on camera it's very
visual it's hard to follow yeah it's not
something anyone would really
do yeah letting go of the weapon for a
second at a time I don't have control
over the weapon you could easily kick it
out of my hand St zal the Split Second
you could [__] somebody up or you could
just drop it the best hit is when they
do that they do that they do that and
then they grab it and they lick it the
licking of the knife is another one very
80s very 80s sexual it's like hey I
could do a lot to you if I want that
never scared me no okay if you if you're
were in an alley and a guy goes like
this come on
sucker like [__] Mister take my wallet
you wait for that second where he throws
it and you kick him in a nuts oh a long
Blade's a Long Blade though you know
that's that's that's a deterrent are we
talking about something something that
you suck at that you're good at you're
terrible at it but you wish you could do
yeah you have to already be bad at it
you're terrible at it bad at it but you
could do well or really well you wish
you could do it well yeah yeah well
there's a difference oh what's the
difference to being good at something or
being like really good at I mean it's
the same for me if I can't whistle I
can't whistle and he can't probably
talking to women there are things
talking to women shut up he stutters a
lot there's things that like yeah what
are the things that you actually
practice for quite some time and you
still suck at oh like breaking oh really
yeah like B Bo you don't practice break
that
much do you practice breaking oh [__] ho
[__] no only when I started only when I
yeah there's no way but if I could be
really good right
now that's why there's a difference
being good at something versus being
really good you got to be like that
crying Asian boy that does all those
crazy ass oh dude that kid is [__] bro
that [__] is oh the little kid
he's that's an alien dude that kid is
INS well I also don't want to be crying
while I'm doing something that I think
I'm really good at you know how many
people sent that in was like this is
Anthony this is Anthony crying while
dancing yes that was like the most
received
every [__] white guy every white guy
is like oh that looks like St like
that's every white guy in the world in
the world and they're all [__] I bet
you it's the same [__] ass accounts but
we love you sign up for our patreon yeah
it's fine sign up for patreon please
sign up for our patreon where you get
the really good exclusive content get
better stuff stuff that we figure out at
the very end of the day cuz we're like
you know it's so good what's the thing
that you suck at that you want to be
good at um okay my actual answer is I
can't I can't crack shitcoins dude you
can't do it no I'm actually serious I
can't crack the shitcoins the shitcoins
are my daddy I can't figure it out
they're my daddy I can't figure it out
like the Doge and she the Sheba coins
the [__] all the [__] garbage
coins Doge bon bon coins but is there
somebody that can is there someone who's
really people make money on all the time
without Insider info I could I could
understand why it feels like that like
dedic what do you mean you can't crack
the I can't crack the [__] coins B I
[__] try I fail cuz imagine all the
stream stories where it's like
somebody's like yo I made like 2 million
off of Sheba or something like this guy
dedicates like I put in $80 and turn
into 8,000 $800 million it's like I I
can't crack it yeah yeah yeah I see I
can't there's nothing I can do I don't
know what we know someone that made 5
mil on sheep see who a friend of a
friend well I don't know him and I don't
I want to crack his brain I don't know
and to me I just I can't crack it and
yet because I do put so much time into
it it's frustrating it's like why are
you working so hard but it's fine cuz I
work hard but I get mine but like I
could get so much more if I could crack
this shitcoin [__] but it's just so
much unfortunately Insider [__] but
you're good but you're good at what you
do yeah but but and like maybe I'm being
a hater when I say that too it's like oh
that's just Insider [__] so I don't want
to do that either be like cop out I
don't want to be excuse maker like oh
it's just Insider [__] oh yeah I don't
I'm not in those groups I don't [__]
know that's that I really don't I think
it's um more like not pop culture but
trends of like hype and has nothing to
do with utility
it definitely has nothing to do with
utility but it doesn't matter because
those people make like [__] 10,000%
or some [__] right so it's like that
would be fun maybe having a pulse on
that but that's also like comparing
yourself to like you worked hard and
made millions of dollars and this person
won the Power
Ball I I would love to just completely
agree with that but like it's a part of
my game that I would love to be be
better at but there are people that make
that understand it so that's where I
think the cracking comes from and and
and maybe it's just a thing of like like
you know cuz I don't put that much into
a lot of different coins I really
believe in not diversifying I think
that's for noobs as [__] but I I think
that there's something to like taking an
allotment and just putting into all
these different [__] coins seeing what
hits like power balls having a budget
for [__] coins for scratchers right
that's what BART did what well no Bart's
really careful he's a careful boyart
remember when you came by one time
you're like Yo dude I just put like
$1,000 to like 10 different like [__]
coins or whatever oh yeah I'm trying to
experiment how did that go uh I don't
remember cuz I remember I ended up just
like this is stupid I just consol I just
Consolidated that's that's what I'm
saying dude it probably would like [__]
cuz like that's what I'm saying unless
you're like in the early early early
days it's really tough and lucky but how
would anyone know about GameStop but
they say I'm lucky so it's it's tough
yeah that's a good question but you are
lucky I know I'm luck dude I'm lucky I
can't get lucky every time but no you're
exactly right that's that's another
problem is like yeah the everyone says
the GameStop thing was like a bunch of
just stupid people who got together but
like people made money on it yeah
there's early adopters they were in the
[__] Wall Street bets and then they
were like oh I'm going jump on this
exactly so it's like how do you be early
I think that's the thing is how do you
be early to it yeah I think you're
probably right can I say for like the
12th time on this [__] Channel golf
my God if I could just do you suck at
golf though he has a good swing I feel
like he don't suck anymore I think when
you talk in the actual game of golf yeah
definitely still no like anybody from
proam would be like oh yeah he sucks I
get it why why would you want to be good
at golf like what kind of satisfaction
you get from that dude the satisfaction
of doing good golf is one satisfying by
itself second the satisfaction of like
if I even was good enough to go like
proam like winning even like [__]
third place in a proam comp would be
like more money than I've ever done and
dance like two times my life over like
that W maybe not two times but you know
I'm saying it's just like the way that
golf is the yeah has so much money in it
let alone like business and like all the
people who are like top execs and
business people so like being able to
network and do that would be so fun
imagine being stuck on a course with
another top business exec but you're
smoking them so you're like hey I want
your business and he's Petty cuz you
smoked them so now he's going to destroy
all your company I only hear great
stories about that Happ there that is
true there's not too many sports where
like being better like it earns the
respect of really powerful people until
ji- Jitsu comes around dude just wait it
yeah wait till hito catches up but
you're on the course for like 4 hours at
a time so imagine that level of network
I've only seen it happen in like
wondrous ways and I'm like yo if I could
just be good at golf opens a lot of
doors huh it does really cuz it's only
the [__] rich and wealthy and
successful anyway that are playing those
spaces and even if you're not rich and
wealthy but you're like a scratch golfer
or better you're going to get through
those doors like that one drunk guy
that's always colorful clothes John Dy
he got in I love that guy he's like the
crazy rock star of golf that would be my
style I I agre I agree with that yeah
but it's just so satisfying regardless
like if you can [__] well cuz you put
time into it I do that's what I'm saying
you actually try but it's like that's
what's interesting I try but I'm still
[__] you work too hard everybody's
putting tons of time in a golf and most
people suck like skaters like skaters
you see in the street well that was me I
worked so hard skating I could only
Ollie I suck at all yeah yeah and then
one time I I hit a rail and I was like
that was so cool couldn't never kickflip
could never do any of the tricks and I'm
like damn I wish I was better at parkour
you know being able to flip through the
[__] City no not really no not really
did you actually practice no I've never
done anything parkour you got to
practice I'm not I don't really have but
if you don't practice you can't complain
that's my model is golf one of those
things where like you can actually get
good in a short amount of time in
adulthood short I don't know about short
like I think it's relative it's like if
you [__] play s days a week maybe a
short amount of time in a sense cuz some
sports if your body didn't develop with
it you're out like ballet for example
right if you didn't start when you're
five impossible to get to the a lot of
dances are like that so I wonder if golf
is golf something where like okay if you
start in your adulthood that's it it's
it's came on tiger started with his dad
when he's like [__] 7 years old he
started when he two and and he came on
the scene when he's what 20 something so
two dude he was ripping prams though but
he was already a Phenom though cuz like
he was doing TV shows as a child I fely
during the
documentary I think I think if there's
like a a translation between your
previous movement career so like for
example like when I go see or play with
other people sometimes they're always
like giving me extra props because as a
beginner I'm terrible as a golfer but as
a beginner it's like Yo dude like maybe
it's because you're a dancer you
understand certain things so so when a
swing coach is telling me he's like you
got to rock your momentum like this I'm
like oh momentum cool or he's like when
he's like right now your swing's like a
V but we need to turn it to more of a u
and I'm like oh [__] tutting yeah that
makes sense to me you know what I mean
so I'm like I understand how to do stuff
with moving mechanics cuz it translates
but I can imagine if you're an adult and
you've never done movement me I'm my D
it's like you're [__] you know
skating with two left feet or whatever
you know it's like it's hard I would
just kill the guy next to me the dancer
who said that and
then there's one less person who says
that and then I can feel more
comfortable about my swing that's so
funny oh my God but that's a really out
of all the sports to get good at that
makes the most sense I think too you
could do it for to an old age yeah
that's the difference when you see old
[__] still playing you're like
okay I'm not I'm not trying to get into
like [__] pro basketball right now
I'm [__] 30 second and and it's a
yeah injuries are low it's a great way
to connect with your
boys yeah off the bask I don't even care
if I'm good at basketball I just want to
down people are constantly going out
there just like drinking smoking you
know what I mean you're just with your
homies Country Club Country Club life
like it's sick Bannon
[Laughter]
juice